sure I was at a school in Brownsville
Brownsville part of brooklyn i grew up
in it's still a very low income area in
in brooklyn as a PS 12 and i was invited
by the new principal now she's 33 years
old Nyree dixon and she's turned it
around from a failing school that was
under review by the state threatened
would being shut down to a school that's
thriving where kids are learning and so
you say well how do you do it well she
is so focused on the quality of teaching
so focused on making sure that children
are on tears the adults are on task with
making sure that that is inviting and
attractive place to be that she has
really transformed the culture gotten
rid of the people who couldn't teach
because they have too many of them there
before and found ways to provide support
for those who are there and they know
exactly what the kids need and they
focus on student needs both the learning
needs but also as important the social
needs hungry kids don't do that well in
school kids who are have basic needs not
being met will often not flourish and so
she has a broad view of what it takes to
educate her children and she's able to
make it happen
well you know I'm not in a position of
either leaving a school or a district I
work as an outsider all times trying to
help trying to encourage trying to push
in some cases and my vision I think
comes from the fact that I get to visit
lots of places lots of schools and and
both see the good in the bed and have a
sense of why the bad is so pervasive and
what it might take to to create more
good and effective schools and so a lot
of my work involves trying to help
particularly the leaders have some
develop a vision that's clear and
compelling but also try to inspire
teachers so that they understand that
the problem is not the kids the problem
is their ability to teach the kids and I
think if you can put the onus back on
them so they have a sense of pride and
responsibility in what they do that
teachers will be a lot more effective
now the other side of that is not
everybody can be a good teacher and part
of we also have to do is let people know
that sometimes they need to find out of
work because they just not cut out for
it
well you know you have so many examples
of leaders who are not effective some
you have people who do punitive so that
anything at T if a teacher asks for help
that's used against them so rather than
Sarah need help with something they will
just close the door and fake it because
they don't want to have someone penalize
them you have leaders who are lazy you
know they sit in their office and they
act as though you can provide leadership
from their office and that never works
you have leaders who to who don't
delegate don't share the leadership so
they put in lots of hours they they try
to make it all happen but schools are
too large and complex for them to be
everywhere and the best leaders know how
to share that responsibilities with
others so the most important thing I
think for principal to realize is that
the the most important work occurring in
the school is in the classroom and since
they're not in classrooms their job
their primary job is to support their
teachers and to create the conditions
that allow their teachers to be
successful which means making sure that
there are adequate supplies that the
building is is running smoothly that
discipline and order or maintained and
that parents and the community are
engaged and those are really important
roles for principals to take on
sure not far from PS 12 which I
mentioned is PS 28 which is bed-stuy the
other side of atlantic avenue this is a
school where over forty percent of kids
are homeless and the the principal
there's 34 highly it's a highly
effective school high-performing school
the principal there when i when i took a
tour there last year she introduced me
to her secretary she said I've trained
my secretary to do most of my
administrative jobs I said well then
what do you do she says I am the lead
teacher at the school I'm in classrooms
all day I work with teachers and I teach
the kids the teachers don't know how to
teach because I want to make it clear to
my teachers that I didn't become a
principal to escape the classroom I
became a principal to be the leader of
the classrooms and I watched her as she
interacted with with teachers and it was
very clear that she saw them as
colleagues as part of a team that even
though she was clearly the leader she
was also there to support them and at
one point said well how do you get along
with the Union she said let me introduce
my union rep and it was very clear that
they were partners in this effort and
working well together so you know what
she has is something that is very
difficult to teach is which is a high
degree of social intelligence she knows
how to work with people she knows how to
bring the best out of people she knows
how to read people and understand their
strengths at one point when I was
visiting the school she said she took me
to a small office where there was a
older man counseling a little boy and I
said she said you see that man there I
said yeah and she says I got him from
the rubber room now those people who
don't know New York the rubber room is a
place where they put teachers and school
staff and nobody wants and they stay
there indefinitely and get paid and so
it's a really horrendous situation so i
said to her i said how did you know to
get him out of the rubber room she said
well i don't know why he was there but
he had been my counselor when i was a
kid in school so when I heard him to the
rubber room I asked for him and I burned
in my school so i sat in and I interest
myself and they interested to the little
boy who was there talking to him so
the counselor said we'll ask this little
boy why he's here today so I said why
are you here boys about eight years old
he says I'm learning how to be good so
you learn how to be good I said it's
working he said I hope so because i'm
tired of get in trouble all the time and
what struck me was it would there was
the it was a conversation it was a
friendly conversation going on between
this older man this little boy it wasn't
about we would throw you out of school
we're going to punish you it was about
trying to really get at the roots of
helping this boy learn to become
responsible for his own behavior not
enough schools do that
well we do a lot of research in schools
so we we study schools we help schools
to understand how they need to change by
helping them to become clear on what the
problems are we think it's very
important that before you go reform
school or change your school that you
clear what the problem is that you make
sure that the remedy matches the problem
which sounds like common sense but
unfortunately it doesn't happen enough
so so it's very important to give
teachers principals a real clear sense
of what they need to focus on in order
to get better results p.s 12 that I
mentioned before they have a great data
person who can give teachers very
precise data on each and every one of
their students so they know exactly what
they need to work on that's very
important if we'd want teachers to be
more effective what they do the
alternative is guesswork and guesswork
doesn't work that well
I see lots of examples you know I see
schools that are using smart boards now
very effectively I barely understand he
was myself still but I'm impressed but
when I see them being used as a part of
instruction because it makes it much
more interactive and the kids seem to
respond extremely well because you know
this is like they're working with
computers and video games all the time
visiting the classroom the other day
where a teacher was using video games to
teach history lesson and kids were
totally engaged there's a math program I
I've been working with now called FG and
it it allowed that the software allows
that can figure out what the student
doesn't understand and take them
backwards so it can figure out what they
what they did learn and then build a
foundation back up and the software is
doing that so the what it does is it
gives the children the ability have more
control over learning which is I think
what we really want so there are a lot
of examples of good technology out there
I always say the most important thing is
to make sure that teachers are
comfortable with using the technology in
many schools the children are more
comfortable with it than the adults and
that's a problem